Okay guys, this is a fictitious critical path method,
arrow diagram, for your PE application and study journey.
We are being asked to find the minimum time and days that it will take for you to complete the project,
aka find the critical path.
So a critical path is simply the sequence of stages that are needed to determine what the minimum amount of time is,
going to be required to complete the project on schedule.
So in this case, it's actually about identifying the longest period of time identified among each of these path options.
So all we have to do is trace each of the paths and sum up their days to find the longest,
because this will determine what the minimum number of days will be,
that would be required to complete the project.
So let's get started.
First, we can check out the path all the way through.
So a to b to c to d to e to f.
So from a to b is 10 days.
From b to c is also 10 days.
c to d, 10 days.
d to e, 5 days.
And e to f is 1 day.
Next, we can look at point a to point c to point d to point e to point f.
So this will be 15 days.
c to d is 10 days.
d to e is 5 days.
And e to f is 1 day.
Then from point a to point e to point f,
this one's very easy to look at.
It's 40 days plus 1 day.
And finally, we can look at a to d to e to f.
So a to d is 25 days.
d to e is 5 days.
And e to f is 1 day.
So if we sum up our different paths here,
we can see that the first one is 36 days.
So, if we sum up our different paths here,
The first one is 36 days.
The second one is 31 days.
The third one is 41 days.
And the fourth one is 31 days.
So our critical path, AKA the shortest amount of time
to complete the project will be the longest or the largest number.
So option three here of 41 days will be our correct answer.